[Music]
we're days away from june 21
but the anticipated freedom day has
perhaps unsurprisingly
been delayed was that the right decision
is actually split opinion in the
spectator offices
i'm joined now by our editor fraser
nelson who argues that a delay is no big
deal
and k andrews edited the spectator's
daily lunchtime briefing
the only roundup of covered news and
analysis that you will need
and she takes a rather different view
fraser i hear you've got a slideshow
prepared after
a few days of disputes in the office
over everyone's views
well i wanted to show why i changed my
mind on this i mean for a long time
i was thinking that the data was showing
that britain had the lowest covert in
the whole of europe
that we had this thing licked certainly
the data seemed to show that
but when the facts change i guess any
journalists ought to change their minds
now we've got the highest
covert levels in europe and that's
because we've got the delta variant
whose behavior is actually very
different just like the
the kent variant so-called beta variants
that
certainly gave britain you might argue a
third wave or perhaps a second stance of
it
to the second wave but when the facts
change you've got to look at this now
what i want to show is what was quite an
influential graph
on me as one we didn't actually run the
spectator because it's hypothetical
but last week's cover story we had um
philip thomas who's a professor of
risk management at bristol university
now i've been following his modelling
because it's been a lot more on the
money than the various sage models we've
had
over the time now he basically asked a
question what if
the um the delta variant the india
variant
is 50 percent more transmissible his
modeling
showed that when it came to deaths they
would be peaking far
fewer than the first wave so you could
certainly say
that that was um about you know in total
there'd be eight thousand deaths
about as many as we're getting a week in
january and
similar to that less than your standard
flu season so that was
about um obviously all the deaths are
tragic but
exit wave was always going to have these
deaths but what really gave me pause was
the graphs he was showing for
infections now if the delta variant was
50 more infectious those infections
would
absolutely surge they'd be way higher
than they were
in january we'll be looking at almost
three million infections a day perhaps a
bit more
now every one of these infections would
uh have so
that of them social isolation you'd have
to stay at home
and your family members would stay at
home kids being sent home from school
now all of this would be happening on
the 21st of june when we lifted
restrictions so you'd have this
very dangerous juxtaposition of the
government saying
okay we're now free to abolish velocity
of the restrictions
and then a biggest surge in cases we'd
ever seen
now i've got um a great belief that
public confidence
is one of the major things that's going
to get us back to normal the government
could abolish all restrictions tomorrow
and you wouldn't get traffic in london
back to what it was surname city where i
go around right now you still see
restaurants
which are half empty and these are like
in the worldly for example i was there
for breakfast on monday
and the breakfast at the woolsey used to
be something you had to book
days if not weeks in advance now it's
still half empty as a lot of restaurants
simply because people like the
confidence
of going out as they once did
now it would not be good for confidence
if the government were to unlock and
then see
absolute surging cases that the
government was struggling to
explain and the biggest question was how
sure can we be
that these surge in cases three million
cases will not lead
to a bigger spike in depth than we
predicted and with the delta variant we
had too little data we simply didn't
know
we didn't know last friday we know a
little bit more now the data's going in
the right
direction and i reckon in two weeks time
we'll know a lot more
we might be able to say with confidence
with a lot more confidence
that yes we will be able to stomach two
million three million more cases
and they simply will not translate into
hospitalizations because we've seen the
data we've done the sums
we know that but when we didn't know
that i couldn't see what was so
bad and waiting another two weeks given
that we waited 15 months
to get that more information and to be
able to come up to prepare the public
for the exit wave and i've i was arguing
months ago my telegraph column
but number 10 needed to start talking
about the exit wave that was inevitable
after lockdown ends so people would have
the confidence
and and that's still my position now i
still think this weight
hopefully it will just be a two-week
wait will give us time to see
how the the um information is going how
the data is going
and will give us more confidence to um
withdrawal
and end the rest of the restrictions
kate do you think the trade-offs are
worth it that bit of extra caution
and which means obviously not everything
returns to normal
and we can debate how much really has
returned to normal
um ultimately that is a trade-off worth
making
so i don't think we should assume it's
going to be two weeks i know fraser was
in support of a two-week delay but the
prime minister made it very clear in his
press conference that it's most likely
going to be four and he wouldn't rule
out
a further delay do i think it's worth it
is almost the wrong question what i've
been asking throughout this entire
crisis and i think was really the basis
of where we
disagreed on the podcast uh last friday
uh which went out on saturday um is
whether or not we can trust the
government to be completely honest with
us at the data we're looking at
if you want to make the case for caution
if you want to say we just want to be
absolutely sure that that link between
infections
and then hospitalizations and sadly
deaths is broken and that way we can be
completely confident
when we reopen in a few more weeks that
we can lift every single restriction
that social distancing can go that mass
can go and we can be free again
i can see the case for it the problem is
that never
once has the government given us the
criteria that they're looking at and the
thresholds that they
are deciding in whitehall as to when the
data is safe to reopen
and it isn't just about this reopening
this was true in lockdowns last year it
was true of the tier system areas like
leicester new that
once they went into the tier system they
basically never came out
they've never been transparent about the
data and the press conference actually
made me
quite nervous i mean i i really hope
that we are now going to open up in
for i guess five weeks time on this new
date but they still
won't tell us what the threshold needs
to be they said where they hope they'll
be with
two-thirds of the adult population
double vaxxed and with
people over the age of 18 all having
their first dose but they didn't say
that was enough they didn't say
it was the criteria and i just am not as
optimistic or as forgiving of the
government as fraser has now
um quite dramatically in a relatively
big reversal
decided to be because we heard it was
three weeks to curb the virus last year
then it was 12 weeks to turn the tide i
think then in
the summer we were told the autumn was
looking good then in autumn we were told
that christmas would go ahead and then
at christmas we were
told that february be looking great and
then in february we were given a road
map that didn't get us out till the
summer
and now we're delayed again and i know
that there are a lot of factors along
the way that change calculations fraser
is right when the data changes
you should change your mind the problem
is that we don't know what the data is
they still
are not being transparent about what
they're willing to tolerate
and i think those graphs that fraser
showed are really very interesting
because we know that reopening society
completely is going to lead
to a big surge in cases there's no way
it won't and so if the government said
we are
focused on hospitalization and death we
just want a bit more data
to that graph that fraser showed where
deaths hopefully don't come anywhere
near the peaks as they did in april or
january i i
understand that argument that makes
sense to me but fraser said he was
spooked by the cases and i think the
government
is spooked by the cases too and if
they're not following hospitalizations
and deaths and they're following cases
we're in a very difficult position
where we're going to see cases go up and
yet they don't want to see cases go up
and that means that it's going to really
be tight
as to when and how we get out of this
and the r rate is now thought to be
around 1.4 1.5 1.6
it's already spreading delaying this by
four weeks
very likely means that whether we come
out on the 21st of june or we come out
on the 19th of july there's a very good
chance that cases will still be going up
as well hospitalizations and as may
deaths
and so it's going to be a difficult
argument to make at any point and the
fact that they
more or less chickened out making the
argument now and have delayed it by four
weeks
it's worrying to me i mean i i hope
they're gearing up to make it they may
well be gearing up to make it but
i just can't have the same level of
optimism because they're not telling us
what data
they're following and if they were
willing to do that i think a lot of
people myself included would be more
sympathetic to the decision that they've
made
fraser we have had michael gove this
week in various broadcast interviews not
just saying he is pretty confident
though
not too long ago apparently he was
saying he would bet on june 21st
but also being pressed on how many
deaths would be acceptable the day from
covert
and ultimately suggesting that from july
19th
the government is just going to have to
live with it do you believe him
do you think when the government talks
about terminus date this time it is
different
i'm afraid to say i don't particularly
believe
look i believe they mean it when they
say it i believe boris johnson meant it
when he said
this time last year that it would over
be over by christmas
and i mean that's the problem with boris
johnson he always he hopes for things
and he
he overspeaks he over promises and you
end up being very disillusioned
i can completely understand why kate is
disillusioned after having the goalposts
moved
time and time again i can see why people
are disillusioned after being given
these
sage scenarios back in the halloween a
press conference on the 31st of october
we were told
showing a scenario of 4 000 deaths a day
way out of kilter
to anything that was even plausible back
then and so i i can see
why you might think well look it was
always going to be a new variant there's
always going to be a new risk
and we're not going to really take any
of this new stuff seriously
but i think the delta variant genuinely
is different genuinely is more
infectious and we genuinely do not know
its dynamics yet
but we are learning every single day
about this in two weeks time we're going
to know a lot more
only a few days ago for example we found
out that the vaccines are actually very
effective against the diazeparian we
didn't know that when kate and i had a
discussion
last friday but we now know there are
basically
the pfizers like 95 effective
hospitalizations against delta variant
and for astra 71 in the first dose and
about mid-90s
for the second dose now these are the
sort of necessary information that you
need to maybe more confident
when you reopen and that's what i'm
talking about just waiting
another couple of weeks to get that data
to say more
with confidence um so i am not
um the f if i was it's funny when you
work out try to work out
do i support the extension am i for
antioch down log down
i don't think anybody can really be
doctrinaire on this
there are certain for example i backed
the first log down because
i thought given how little we knew about
the virus hunkering down made sense for
a while i thought it went on
for far too long i think the government
and deeply
worsened the damage on the economy and
society by not reopening last summer
earlier not reopening the schools when
it could um so throughout all of this
i guess all of us we try to look around
and make sure that we're not
blinkered we're not locked into any one
position that we do
look at the changing situations and i
guess these are very difficult
situations the government's making every
time
very difficult indeed there are lives to
be lost on both sides
it's a balance of risk and i guess what
we can do is think well that was my
decision what would i do
and when i was talking to kate last
friday and when i'm talking right now
i know what i would do if it were up to
me i would want to wait for a couple of
weeks
because i think the date is coming very
quickly and i think there is a case to
be made
saying right we are going to have an
exit wave it's better we have it in the
summer
then we pilot upon extra cases in the
winter but this could be quite a big
wave for example
right now if you get pinged by the nhs
you need to self-isolate for um
for 10 days or two weeks now you know in
america
if you've had the virus or if you've
been double vaccinated you don't need to
self-isolate but don't think you're
going to be
infectious but if we're going to have
three million cases
in britain if that's a scenario that
we're looking at i don't know how many
more millions of people
are going to be pinged by the nhs app
until to stay at home the government
needs to start thinking about that
right now so i do think that the delta
variant is something which
it has really changed the calculations
it's not too much to ask i think
for another couple of weeks now sure the
government might keep us stringing on
i might be joining kate in um in
demanding in two weeks time but the
government
does go ahead and do a full reopening
but right now i'm i'm trying to keep an
open mind
frozen just on that i mean there are
documents out i mean that have been
leaked
um cabinet office documents which are
saying that after july 19th some
measures will stay and one the
government is really considering is the
fact that self-isolating
being pinged will stay and there's a
chance that the double vaccinated may be
able to
get off there if they do a test today
but that doesn't really sound like
freedom or is that in your view a
sensible health precaution going forward
i think that's difficult normally i'm
dead against um anything that comes into
a system of immunoprivilege anything
which would
segregate a divine britain based on
their immunological status
but on a practical basis if a scenario
we're looking at is millions of people
being pinged all the time
then i do think there is logic behind
the nhs which after all has got records
of everybody who's been vaccinated
everybody has been told they've got
covert
or the nhs could think we're not going
to ask you to self-isolate
if you if you've had covered or if
you've had a double jab because we don't
realistically think that you're going to
spread it
to anybody else now this is a very
complicated
question i can see the the arguments on
both sides here i would rather it wasn't
raised at all
but if the delta variance is anything
like as infectious as we think and by
the way those figures might still be
wrong it might be nothing like
as infectious we currently fear but if
we are looking at millions of new cases
we're looking at millions of new people
being pinged already you can see it
um happening in schools all the time
right now it's getting back to what it
was in the build up
to january so i do think people you need
to be strategic about are we really
going
to have um you know several million
people self-isolating
even if there's no reason for believing
that there stand any risk of
transferring the virus to others
kate so i brought with me a few of the
spectators recent magazines for the
sake of the the leaders that were
published in them this is from the 5th
of june
the title on the website was the
vaccines are a game changer
covet is losing its sting and loads in
here about how cases shouldn't be what
we're following
and i think my favorite was um in our
may
22nd edition why britain must unlock on
the 21st of june because
you know i think it's important to
realize how quickly this debate has
shaped
has shifted within the spectator itself
i didn't think i had to bring
are many many many articles
and leaders and comment pieces on
vaccine passports
or on immuno privilege something that we
have been starchy against and
this change in rhetoric fraser and the
fear
that you're putting forward makes me so
concerned about
what we're actually going to get back
because even as we talk about reopening
on the 19th of july we are not talking
about real life still i mean i deeply
hope that every business
is able to reopen i hope that we get rid
of limits on gathering so family
reunions can get back together
my friends can have their weddings and
and people can live their lives again
but the prime minister in his press
conference was talking
he was hinting that there may still be
restrictions in place as katie says
we're seeing leaked documents about
working from home guidance about masks
we know that travel isn't going to go
back to normal
probably for years we still don't know
on the 19th of july
what will happen with social distancing
because in a very untransparent manner
opaque manner i should say
they took it out of the road map so
we're still having to fight on the
grounds of actually getting freedom back
now we're having to fight on the grounds
that maybe we should be able to have
more than six people in our home
and now i'm hearing that there might be
a case for immuno privilege i mean this
is how
liberty dies this is how it fails we
don't have anybody in government or very
few
shout out to the mps that are making the
case for these things
we cannot buckle here and everyone is
taking this
very very seriously i too have been in
support of the first lockdown and the
third lockdown because the nhs
cannot be overwhelmed but we've moved so
far past making the case
for caution and making the case for
science and vaccines do they break the
link
between infections hospitalizations and
deaths now moving into well it might be
a bit
practical to take away some liberties we
should be questioning the system itself
if we have gotten covered under control
then let's talk about scaling back
all of those restrictions that are still
on our lives what are the appropriate
ones if you have kovid stay home
absolutely but is it sensible for
anybody if they are paying
to be legally forced to do x y or said
let's at least have the debate
you know i think people with far greater
scientific knowledge than us can have
that debate but
the fact that we are moving so far away
from it means that the debate
isn't going to happen at all um and i
suppose i just find that
very very sad because people of all ages
from all backgrounds have given up
so much of their lives now so much to
protect their loved ones and strangers
people they've never met before
because it was the right thing to do but
now the primary goal should be to give
that all back to them and frankly more
especially for young people who are not
at severe risk
of getting very sick or dying from this
virus to actually deal with some
some of those intergenerational
inequalities that that they've been
dealing with for so long
and now we're talking about immuno
privilege and
you know whether or not people are still
going to be forced to do all kinds of
things
on so-called freedom day i mean if we
don't make the case phrase or who will
phrase we are making the case all the
time but the thing is we're not doing
this
saying like come what may i mean right
now to take for example back in may
when of course i at the time was very
much wanting the 21st of june to be the
day we end all restrictions
there was nothing on the horizon back
then to think that we were going to get
another wave in cases
far bigger than the second wave when
something like that changes
if it's plausible then i do think you
need to
just change your mind when the facts
change if this is this is what rational
people do this is i don't think
following what facts are they following
they won't tell us they didn't tell us
in the press conference
and they won't tell us now the facts
which you're following is quite it's
quite simply this that until we can be
sure and again
we're talking about two weeks this is
not i completely agree okay
everything everything you say but all
the sacrifice people have made about
disruption
to society about the disruption to the
economy and i think
it could well i think it will probably
take us about two or three years to
really calculate all the harm
that's been done by these restrictions
which are absolutely not being
calculated or made
clear by the government but after 15
months here
if we're talking about another two weeks
to be able to say to the public
that yes we're going to unlock now yes
we are ready for there to be two
three million more infections and we are
confident we are confident
that they're not going to disrupt
because of because first of all we've
got the vaccine
to show it works with new data variant
we've got that now we didn't have it
last week
because we've got the figures showing
that this does not convert to
hospitalizations
we don't have our data now we probably
will have it in one or two weeks we'll
be in such a good position
to restore the confidence and is the
confidence that we need to start to
repair
the damage to society in the country the
government the government could tomorrow
flick a switch and say
all restrictions are off it would still
take people a long time have a look at
the opinion polls they're saying
that most people want the restrictions
to be extended
now this might seem crazy to to people
who on the more liberal side
of the argument but that goes to show
that confidence is the nut
to crack here governments cannot
legislate to make people
think that there isn't a risk out there
anymore and if we are
going to exit into a massive third wave
a scenario that nobody
absolutely nobody envisaged in the
middle of
may because we had no idea about the
delta variant then you do need to
um well put it this way to wait for two
more weeks to get more
to get more facts to be certain to give
people that confidence
i don't think it's too much to ask i
don't think it's a big reversal i don't
think it's a betrayal of any values
it's simply common sense and that's been
i think the spectator's position all
along
fraser just finally um i wanted to ask
do you think there's a generational
element to all this too because
uh ultimately i suppose stage free of
the road map which
allows indoor dining drinks like one you
recently had with douglas murray in the
pub
um and some actual socializing probably
isn't that dissimilar to what i i
suppose someone
who ready you know has their family
lives in a house
as compared to i suppose what a young
person wants to do which is probably
closer to stage four not just talking
about nightclubs here but
i suppose just the freedom of choice to
meet new people and things about
having to go through all the steps you
currently have to do
well on that point you can certainly say
like touche or my personal point of view
i'm not somebody who
bothers the bouncers of london
nightclubs uh too frequently
normal times but then again i am a
parent of of kids
who have been having to self-isolate and
having their their um
education deprived of them i think all
of us feel this
in certain ways but again like in saying
that i think there is logic in the
government's case for waiting another
couple of weeks to
think about this more carefully i don't
i don't think i'm acting i don't think
i'm doing this from purse
from selfish point of view i could try
to x-ray my soul here
and work out same is there something
about this lockdown that i like no i
absolutely hate and despise
this lockdown that stops us getting
people back here together at the
spectator it stops us
seeing the readers that we'd like to see
we're having to we're for so many things
which i think are vital
um you know for what the spectator does
and in us in a sort of professional
capacity
but for what we as a society do there's
so many things and other things i won't
bore you enlisting that i would like to
do i would love to go back to see my
um my in-laws in sweden it breaks my
heart that i haven't seen them for 18
months i'm probably not going to see
them
this summer at all my my kids are will
not be able to practice their swedish
you know
everybody has got a story of how this
lockdown has disrupted them it's
certainly true
the people of my generation and who
basically
own their own home we've got a family
who've got a garden but lockdown has
affected people like that a lot and
worse
a lot less but this affected either
those affected by the virus who are most
likely to end up
in hospital or have lived the last 18
months in fear of going to hospital
and it's affected a lot less than the
younger people who for example haven't
been able to do internships have been
robbed of the education which they need
to might even school should never have
been closed
in this country so yes there is a
generational
aspect my generation people i guess
people in the late 40s middle-aged
people who are married
with houses and families perhaps it's
affected us less
than everybody else but i like to think
when most people
say what they want for long time not
just for that but for the society
they try to think for the country as a
whole now for a country as a whole i
fervently want us to be able to make the
recovery that israel's been able to make
but israel's been able to make that with
confidence and i don't think
that until the government can assure
people that there's nothing to fear from
a delta variant
we're not going to have that confidence
that's what i want i don't think it can
be done by a policy switch
i do think it can be done by another two
weeks of data i just simply in short
do think it's worth that short wait okay
you get to have the final word
well fraser's completely right that life
is a lot better now than it was back in
february
and and i know that he's following this
data closely closely as we both have
been doing throughout this crisis
and if he were making the decisions and
making them based on caution around
hospitalizations i'd feel
i feel quite good about that i would
have that confidence that he's
describing
the problem is that he can't and
apparently no minister
who's actually responsible for telling
myself and our and our viewers
they can't tell us what data they're
following they won't tell us
what data they're following and there's
a confidence that's lost with that as
well
we cannot downplay the pain that will be
caused
by this month delay uk hospitality
expects that it will cost
that sector 3 billion pounds you know we
may be able to go sit in a restaurant
sit in a pub and
have a nice time with a friend but a lot
of these places that are open aren't
being able
aren't able to turn a profit they're
just just
struggling to get by um for the tourism
industry which relies on those summer
months a huge chunk has been taken out
and
they lost so much last year already
isn't that about confidence kate it's
about confidence and that's the thing i
mean
to get confidence you do need to be able
to persuade people that delta
isn't going to be the threat which most
people whether you and i like it or not
most people think
that it is going to be that threat and
as we've discussed i take that very
seriously but i'm not at all convinced
that in four weeks time
the government is going to be in a
stronger position to build up that
confidence when i suspect because of
where the rate is now
cases and hospitalizations will be
rising but the major point i want to
make here
is that regardless of whether you want
to be more cautious a bit more bullish i
think there's strong arguments on
both sides and in fact i really do
sympathize with that cautious argument
make sure that link is broken so we
never have to do it again
we're not being given that information
and meanwhile
people are missing out on major life
experiences and they matter
they're struggling to keep their
businesses afloat they're not able to
get married
they're not able to make somebody not
able to meet somebody new if you had
told us two years ago
that a month of our lives was going to
be locked down we would say that is
absolutely horrendous but people as
fraser said do care about others they
care about society
so we've done it on and off for 15
months we cannot take that out of
context an additional four weeks
is on top of 15 months of already doing
this and it is reasonable
not to say press the button and open
everything not to say
do what you want it doesn't matter
anymore but to ask the government
what data are you following and what do
you need to see what are you looking at
not what
fraser quite rightly is looking at not
what i'm looking at for the coveted
email
what are you looking at to open those
doors and they still won't tell us
[Music]
you